[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
director at the long now foundation as
many of you know we have been working
towards funding our salon project and
just this last week after a flurries
flurry of great donations we passed our
halfway point which means we're going to
start construction next month so thank
you all and other big news with that is
that Brian Eno agreed to do all the
ambient sound for the whole space as
well as a video installation in the back
room that will be sound and video
specific for the space so we're super
excited to have that we're still two
hundred thousand dollars away from
finishing our fundraising but we hope to
be there by the time we open which will
be about six months so early 2014 before
these talks we do we we try and do a
long short a short film that exemplifies
long term thinking and this week's is
one or this months is one that comes to
us from a long now member who did a
project with the Exploratorium and I
believe also was supported by the
awesome foundation a lot of kind of
cross paths and encounter you hear there
you are right there thank you very much
for this video
you offered it to us a long time when
we've been trying to find the right path
for it and Craig childs seem like the
the perfect one for it when we roll it
we're also going to show you a new piece
of video that was done by an animator
James Anderson I was organized by by
Chris Baldwin our videographer and the
sound for it was done by Brian Eno for
us it's the ten seconds of long now
identifier that's going to roll before
all of our talks online but tonight
we're going to show it just before the
the long short so enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm a Stuart brand from the long now
foundation it's pretty interesting to
hold a whole year in your mind for a few
minutes like that what would be like to
experience a whole eon the events that
occur in eons on the planet I was
talking with our speaker tonight just a
few minutes ago and we were talking
about once you get off I didn't do a
boondock even a pretty close boondock or
even just look straight overhead from
the Exploratorium you get out of the
short now pretty fast and engage a
different frame of time
the planet is not normal right now and
we usually take blame for that the
improper scene we're screwing up the
climate we're doing this and that but it
wasn't normal before we started screwing
it up we're in an interglacial normal in
the last few Young's has been ice and
normal that other times has been
seriously different from the current I
think this is gonna I just realize this
we start exploring other planets or
knowing more about other planets from
remote sensing we're not going to find
them in a state of welcome to humans we
might put them into a state of welcome
for humans if we're powerful enough to
get there but planets do lots of strange
things and what's wonderful about this
one is that it doesn't do the same thing
everywhere and so we have a speaker who
is intrepid enough to go to the places
where it is extremely out of this period
of time and so Ethan lot more than just
looking up from the sky at the
Exploratorium he's looking into how a
really dynamic planet behaves way out of
human control or even in most cases
perception I recommend his book which is
available in the lobby apocalyptic
planet I first came across him through
earlier book called House of rain where
the way he inspected how the
civilizations of the southwest must have
come and gone with climate and other
events was just went out and walk hike
spent a serious time in the bush
experiencing what they must have
experienced as they went from canyons to
mountains to desert to this place in
another it's a pretty interesting way to
recreate history in this case he's
recreating and even longer history
that Creek Charles Hayter hi there I'm
just down from Alaska been out traveling
seeing things looking at the planet
looking at looking at ice up up in the
mountains that are just mouthfuls of
glaciers coming down and out of the
Kenai Peninsula and down into over into
Prince William Sound places where where
ice is floating out in the water right
now it's it's it's melting it's heading
into high summer and up there the sun's
not really setting it's just doing that
kind of that tilted hula hoop that it
does in Alaska during the summer
it changes your perception of time I I
saw the Stars for the first time two
nights ago I haven't seen them for for a
while before then this this planet we
live on this earth is a storyteller
everywhere you go out there it is it is
telling a story in in the way that wind
moves across Rock the way the star is
moved through the sky and the moon light
comes on you go out there and you move
in it and you can feel time around you
you can feel the the forces that affect
this planet forces that collide and
forces that that intertwine and creates
you you really get a sense of of how
time unfolds when you're out there when
you're in it when it's live and it's
real and it's under your feet and the
the sand is in your teeth and and you're
drinking the water out of the cups out
of the the holes in the rock where the
rain gathers the earth is a storyteller
everywhere you go out there it tells a
story
I stopped in in Yosemite National Park
for a couple days on my way through to
here and and I realized out there
how clearly you see it when you when you
look at this this landscape this is this
is this morning sunrise hitting any
hitting half-dome and and and you look
at this and and you see that things are
on a completely different scale than
then they should be that you look at the
the creeks in Yosemite and there are
these little creeks flowing through
these big big drainages where where the
the scale is off and you realize that
something big happened here go back to
the the end of the Pleistocene go back
twelve thousand fifteen thousand years
ago as the ice was falling apart and
melting and and rivers were just roaring
down out of these glaciers you walk in
this place and you can see what happened
before you can see the other times
around you and and you get a sense of
how time moves that that it comes in
these small increments of the the
shadows moving over the rock and in
these large increments of being able to
see where the glaciers just poured and
flowed through these valleys and filled
up these valleys until the mountains
just their their summits were sticking
up above the ice the first thing I did
when I got there is I put my back
against some some of the ice polished
granite and I just looked up at the sky
and watched the clouds move and just
marveled at the the fact that this this
big old granitic batholith was was
shoved up into the sky in a place where
the glaciers would climb all over it and
sculpt it it's it's like putting a big
chunk of marble on a on a sculptors
front doorstep and saying have at it and
that's what happened to Yosemite the ice
went and had at it and you're thinking
in those timescales at the same time
that you're you're watching the shadows
move across the rock you're watching the
day progress and you're feeling
underneath your feet that slick polish
of granite where ice has been moving
everywhere you go out there it tells a
story while I was there on my back I
realized that that I hadn't put the
pieces together that I had just been in
in Alaska traveling on an ice field that
has swallowed a bunch of mountains and
and I had been skiing with with sleds
and ropes across this this ice field and
and now I was at the bottom on my back
looking up through what would have been
a thousand feet of ice so I could see
myself skiing way up there way over my
head this is this is what it looks like
here and this is what it looks like
there this is a this is the Harding
Icefield which is about a thousand
square miles of ice sitting up on top of
the Kenai Peninsula with with glaciers
pouring down and and and it is just it
is an elemental landscape which is what
I'm really looking for I go out in into
the world looking for these places that
are that are reduced that are primary
they come down to white ice snow rock
these nunataks these these summits of
mountains sticking up through the ice
you know I was looking at this this
picture right here and then looking
yesterday at this in Yosemite and and
realizing oh they these are the same
things just that it's it's over here
it's already happened and it's not over
up there where you're skiing across ice
surfaces that are that are about a
thousand feet deep and you're just
feeling the weight of that ice
underneath you setting your camps up on
the surface of the Harding Icefield and
moving on carrying your gear listening
to the the slide of your your skis and
the sled on snow moving across this
elemental terrain that just that just
fills your senses the curve asses that
are sight the size of buildings that
drop down into darkness you want to go
around those
don't go through them I've heard some
people say you feel small in the
wilderness when you go out to places
like this but I actually believe it's
more that you lose your sense of scale
when you go out there because there we
were just tiny dots the whole time but
were we small or could you just not tell
the size of things I love those
landscapes that just obliterate your
sense of scale where you don't know if
you're small or if you're large you
can't tell because it is just the world
everything is one-to-one scale it is all
equal when you're out there and these
nunataks that's the word for the the
mountains that are completely surrounded
by ice they're these they're magical to
see and and they're they're just they're
just poking through and you know that
the the rest of the mountain is down
beneath and the nunataq is just the last
part that the glaciers haven't been able
to digest and as opposed to Yosemite
where you have to climb way up to get on
top of the mountains here you just ski
up to the summits it's much easier
except for the crevasses but remember go
around and and just trust that your snow
bridge will sustain your weight
underneath you you go up on to these
nunataks and you climb up on top and you
look around and you're surrounded by the
ice field and by the other mountains
sticking up and your sense of time and
process is very different from the
everyday from moving from waking up in
the morning and getting your coffee and
all the the pieces in parts of our lives
I mean we spend so much time in these in
these boxes and and I spend so much time
on my computer underneath the roof
that's hiding the Dome of the sky all
you have to do is walk outside I mean
just opening the door and leaving this
building at the end of the day you will
walk out there and you will taste the
wind you will see the fog moving through
you will see this world that is
constantly changing
I I when I wrote apocalypse
planet I was I was interested in seeing
landscapes that that showed the earth in
its most elemental forms and and you
know they're in a sense their endings
they're I'm looking at a desert
efficacious sea level rise loss of
glaciers or encroachment of glacial
periods looking out to asteroid impacts
volcanism mass extinctions looking for
landscapes around the world that tell
this story where you go into it and you
can see that's that one story in front
of you so since we're on the topic of
ice I want to take you to a place where
I'm looking at the world as it as it is
in a glacial period how to to the
Greenland ice sheet
I flew in in 2010 to a small camp a
seven person camp out on the on the west
side of the the Greenland ice sheet and
and my object here was to was to see a
place just locked in ice no mountain
sticking out nothing alive just just I
swear when you land this is in May it's
it's a it's it's 20 below it's it's it's
a cold and windy and and nasty place
which I just I love those places because
I you know very quickly you forget
everything else about the world the
whole earth becomes locked in ice the
the plane lands you unload a thousand
pounds of gear underneath the wing and
the wind is just skating by and rapidly
puts these these shark fins of
snowdrifts behind your gear and and and
the the plane takes off and there's
there's nothing more magical than being
dropped in a place like this and
watching the plane leave there were
there were two of us who were dropped
off the the camp the camp had been
closed all winter and and so we were
there to open it up and and what added
to this this sense of wonder as the
plane is leaving is that the other guy
with me he was a Kaos researcher Jose
rial from
North Carolina University he he had been
here this was his sixth season and as
he's marching to the camp he's he's
cursing going oh my god what happened
what happened to this place so I'm
watching the plane go and I'm looking
over saying what do you mean what's
going on and and and he's he was saying
a third of camp is gone it's just gone
and and I'm looking around thinking well
there's mostly a bunch of snow machines
here and they're gone too and and and as
I look closer I can see that the front
door is open on the tent and and the
snow is just drifted in and filled it up
and and we're the ice that we're on
about five thousand feet of ice right
here and and I'm shouting back to him
where where are the snowmobiles and he's
saying I don't know they're down there
somewhere and I'm looking down going
well this is 5,000 feet of down there
where where exactly down there are you
talking about so we we started looking
around and found that the camp had just
been ravaged by storms that the weather
stations were down the solar panels had
catapulted off and and the place was
just a mess and so we started digging
our way into it Jose was the first one
to slide in through the door into the
kitchen tent here and and then I was
working on the the research tent next to
it clearing it out and when I when I
finally got the door open and inside
this is what I saw this this this frozen
Inferno where you you walk back into it
and and stalactites of ice crystals are
hanging off the ceiling and you can just
brush your your hand through them and
they just they sprinkle to the ground
this is this is the desk of Konrad
Steffen who is who is one of the lead
cryosphere authors for the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change which I just think it's perfect
that is his desk is just absolutely
buried
and then digging it out is this isn't
this isn't like the snow we know around
here this is this this it's like digging
through wall board where you have to
break it off in chunk and then carry
these chunks outside it is it is just
compacted back in here and so I I am
excavating his desk and finding all the
the pieces of electronics he left at the
end of the last season and and some of
his notes and and this which I think I
think when you're working as a scientist
and climate change you need that because
I mean you spend time with climate
researchers and and this story starts
looking pretty dire so so you know we've
uncorked it take a swig now Jose is a is
a chaos researcher in climate change
perfect person to be up there he be up
there with because he's he's always
looking for he was always telling me you
know we we have predictions and models
but what happens is always what you
don't expect and and I talked to him
about ice ages you know and he he said
yeah we could be looking at another Ice
Age coming up soon nobody else says that
but the chaos person does you pull your
head out of the tent and you look around
and this is what you see just this this
emptiness surrounding you where it's
it's it's just one scale there is no
large no small it feels as if there is
almost no time you are just here now and
it looks flat but it's actually it's
undulating very slowly and and camp is
moving because the whole ice sheet is
moving I think camp is moving at about a
foot per day and when it was originally
built in 1993 or in the early 90s it was
up on top of one of these crests and now
it's down in the trough and so this the
camp is just surfing its way along the
ice sheet and the ice is is
is moving on down to the coast where it
where it dumps and this dumps out in the
Jakob Safin glacier which is the largest
producer of icebergs in the world or at
least in the normal Northern Hemisphere
and the same year I was out this this
footage was taken at the at the end of
the Jakob saman glacier of a an iceberg
a few hundred feet tall breaking off and
then collapsing so this is where camp is
heading eventually it will it will drop
into this and and well maybe that's
where we're all heading eventually and
you go down to the the the Jakob Safin
glacier and you watch the these icebergs
coming off it's just like these these
floating white cities out there just
constantly being produced and moving out
in front of you to give you a sense of
scale that there's a 40-foot long boat
right over there
and I I spent 13 hours one day just
sitting here in this one spot watching
the icebergs come and go and and and
you'd look out in the distance and see
these these just enormous ones floating
out there and and you just realize that
the scale of the forces around you that
this planet is moving ice is flowing
down and dumping into the sea and you
stay there until midnight watching the
ice moving around you now up on the ice
sheet itself you don't see any of this
movement other than you know you're
moving a foot a day but you can't see it
the only movement out there is the wind
which is constant even even when it's
not blowing this is a moment where the
wind isn't blowing you know it's just
skating across the surface everything is
being continually sculpted around you
and I'm out there just just looking back
at the earth history just thinking how
we are still right now technically
within an ice age we are in a period in
Earth's history where there is still a
lot of ice on the planet that swings in
and out of glacial and interglacial
periods but we're in and I
age and many of the climate change
researchers that I that I worked with
that I that I interviewed and spent time
with for this book we're talking about
how we are we are probably leaving this
period of ice ages we're entering a new
period in Earth's history and and you
know I that terrifies me because I I
like where we are right now I think the
the Holocene is save the Holocene it's
it's it's the great time on earth at
least for us for for our kind and the
species around us it's is a marvelous
time because you know look back there
there have been periods long long ago
where we're you know billions of years
ago where the earth was encased in ice
where the where Equatorial seas were
bobbing with slush and you had a white
planet you know not a not a friendly
place not not like this place we are now
and that's what I wanted to get a look
at here I wanted to wanted to just see
what is ice about what is it about to
live in a time where where there's
nothing but white all around you in the
coming days different members of the the
crew arrived and and we we slowly dug
out the the ski-doos that had been that
had collapsed into the the snow while
the wind is blowing around us and it
took us days to get these things out and
at night you're in your your your tent
and the the wind is building snow up
around you and the tent is getting
smaller and smaller all night long it's
pushing on the back of your head until
you're going fetal because the walls are
closing in and you've got a piece of
automotive hosing sticking hose sticking
out of the the top of the tent just in
case you get totally sealed off you can
still breathe out of this thing
and all night long you're feeling the
weight of the snow building up on you
that's that I guess I go out looking for
this for what is what is visceral about
these stories I look at the this science
I talked to the researchers but then I I
walk out there into it to feel what it's
life
it's windy out there
and for me it is just so beautiful
because it's reduced all the pieces and
parts that were used to or stripped away
I think I'll stay inside and you go out
in the morning and you look at these
shapes that the wind has sculpted around
you these these beautiful teardrops and
starships of snow it's it's a you you
can see the processes of the planet on
so many scales when you're when you're
in places where it's just reduced where
it is it is ice it is sky it is wind it
is wind that is carving these these
forms across the surface of the ice
sheet and and I want to be there when
it's happening that's why I'm a I'm
excited to be on this planet right now
you know as as we're talking about going
from from the Holocene to the
Anthropocene as we're talking about
major changes I there's something about
being there when it's happening I I went
to the research station in May because I
wanted to see the the transition from
winter into summer which is like a
six-day transition at the the
temperature is going up by half a half a
degree per day I wanted to be there at
that moment where it happened where
where you could you could sit on the
south-facing side of the the tent and it
was warm where the Plexiglas window on
the on the kitchen tent had been had
been frozen solid just this block of ice
and then it melted and the the reason
camp was was originally put in this spot
was this is this is where the snow never
melts this is where the the glacier the
the ice sheet is continuing to grow and
so they're there studying the the
movement of the ice at this at this spot
so you're
you know this is this is continually
winter here even in the summer it stays
frozen but while I was there it warmed
up it warmed up enough that you could go
outside and you could take the first
showers and and I turned from this into
this it started to melt and like I said
this is 2010 a couple months later this
is an aerial view of the camp you can
see that the melt has come inland and
just gone past the camp so a place that
has remained frozen year-round is no
longer frozen it is melted out there's
there's the camp there and for the first
time since the early 90s
this camp completely fell apart and you
see the change happening and yeah we
live on a planet that is constantly
changing I mean we live on this this
planet of cycles of rhythms of seasons
seasons that happen in throughout a year
seasons that happen over centuries over
thousands of years swings up and down
but then you have episodes you have
moments of sudden change and that's
where the the Jose the chaos researcher
kept talking about these jumps you would
say yeah the the earth is is going into
one of these jumps and you don't know
what its gonna be on the other side of
those jumps where we're talking as if
the Ice Age has ended and we're leaving
the ice but you don't know when it jumps
it could go anywhere we could we could
drop back into a glacial period we're
experiencing a jump the earth is always
jumping this is not a stable place to
live we look at the mountains and the
and the rivers and and we think these
this is the way it's always been I mean
the it seems that way we want it to be
that way I want it to be that way I
don't want the Holocene to end I want it
to be like this forever doesn't happen
if you want to see melt the place to go
is is South America is to the is is to
the mid lat
dude glaciers I traveled a couple years
ago down to northern Patagonia and in in
Chile on a trek with with a film crew we
went out for a month crossing these
these glaciers coming down off the
northern northern Patagonian ice field
and this these are the largest non polar
ice masses in the world
I think it's eight thousand square miles
of ice sitting on top of the the Andes
this this is right at the edge of the
ice field where where it's just it's
just pouring around these summits down
into these glaciers into the valleys
below and and we were trekking up along
the basis of these of these glaciers and
this is a place where a glacier in the
70s came over this pass and down into
the next Valley where I had been talking
to Gauchos who said oh yeah we used to
pasture up here but then there was a big
wall of ice and you could see where the
wall of ice had been because there are
no trees there and and they told me how
fast it retreated up and over this pass
and it had been on top of this past just
a few years before we got there so this
place is just freshly scoured from a
glacier retreating back to the the
mother glacier back there it retreated
so recently that the ground is still
dewatering creeks are still coming out
of these these high passes where the ice
had been and you're walking through this
place that that is just it's booming
because these there Big Sur racks big
big faces of ice falling off some of
them are four or five stories tall
breaking free from up in the mountains
are down along the glacier glacial front
and just all night long you're hearing
these booms you're in your tent and and
and some of them are loud there you feel
them through your back just this boom
and you just wake up going ah where hey
Patagonia ok paddocks rack ice ok oh
it's such a loud place and it feels like
you're within the geologic gears of the
earth and they're grinding against each
other there they're turning and and
and and there's nothing to give
scale-out there there's nothing there
are no trees everything's been been just
erased from from the land because the
mountain has just been clawed out and
you look over at these pieces of ice and
you think you could reach over and just
pick them up and put them in your mouth
and so you walk over to them and you
find that they're much larger than you
had anticipated but still you you you
take off a piece and you put it into
your mouth and it turns to water and you
drink it and you're thinking this has
been ice for a thousand years or maybe
five thousand years and now it's turning
to water I want to be there at that
moment that it changes I want to know
what that change is like some of these
these pieces of the former glacier just
they're just lying around like mansions
big pieces of ice where you can you can
go into them and and you just run your
hand across there they're surface it's
it's like wet marble cold wet marble and
you know we all relate to it differently
this is a friend who is a rock climber
named Timmy O'Neill kind of a crazy guy
this is his relationship with these
pieces of ice what we need is a really
big tumbler a giant lime shitload of gin
I mean you got to find a way of relating
to it right I I found while writing
apocalyptic planet I did not want to
just be writing about how it's all
coming to an end like yes the world is
ending it's always ending the end is not
a moment the end is not there's a flash
and it's all over suddenly everything's
covered with ice or suddenly it's all
melted and it's all desert now or
everything is extinct all at once the
end is is a process it's something that
the it's it's change
I don't see it as necessarily runaway
planet toward one singular end it is it
is something that is that is constantly
changing and dynamic you get up on top
of this this these glaciers and and
they're loud with running water it
you're hearing these rivers forming
underneath you just the ice is rumbling
it sounds like a ship engine below deck
where where water is is coursing down
through these mulan's into the interior
of the glacier and you look down these
holes and and you're looking down into
this this blue within blue it's it's
it's this that's just beautiful color
that's so rich it feels perilous just
just to look inside of it and you you
find some crack some crevasse and you
crawl down into it and you follow the
water where it's sculpted its way inside
the glacier
and you know you think that you'd feel
claustrophobic in here but it feels like
you just wedged by your shoulders this
is the head of the the real Baker the
the largest river in Chile and this is
where it begins we actually on this Trek
we we we started there and as soon as
the river was large enough which it's
not far down from here we moved two
kayaks and rafts and ran it all the way
out to the sea just to complete the
whole cycle and then back up to the
glacier we were making a circle out of
ourselves the ice has been melting and
it forms these lakes that are backed up
behind ice dams and the lakes have been
blowing out creating what are called
Glaus glacial lake outburst floods and
and and there are these enormous floods
that have been coming down this this is
the the Colonia glacier in in him in
Patagonia and and this this hadn't seen
very many Glaus and in recorded history
and then and then three years ago lake
started building up on the surface and
then exploding out the downstream end
and these these enormous floods have
been coming out this is this is the the
exit wound of one of these floods the
the terminus of the glacier is is
probably about a hundred feet tall just
to give you a sense of scale that that
right there is a big chunk of ice that's
covered with sand and here it is when
we're next to it and these things are
just are exploding out of the end of the
glacier in the in these floods and and
the floods are large enough that they
they travel 40 miles downstream they hit
the Rio Baker which is which is an
enormous river you know the the largest
in Chile and the the floods actually
turned the river around and the river
flows upstream for 20 miles for the next
few days so it's flooding all these
upstream
so these are these are significant
events and they're they're happening
right now
once a month so these these floods have
been building up these large lakes
building up exploding out the other side
we paddled this this ducky out to get a
look at the the terminus of the glacier
where it's just junk it's just floating
pieces of ice where you you put on your
crampons and you try to walk across the
stuff but you're walking on rolling logs
of ice and I do not advise doing this
but when you're out there you're hearing
the glacier cracking you're hearing the
terminus and and and we're thinking okay
well a flood could come but you know we
got it we got like a three-hour window
here to get in and have a look at it and
get out and there's not gonna be a flood
within those three hours and I remember
at one point there was just this sound
that sounded like a metal eye beam
snapping in half and the terminus of the
glacier it was just this pinging and we
all just stopped and we're just staring
at it just waiting you know it's this
thing gonna open up and out comes the
flood and and just you know that moment
of looking at each other going no no
everything's fine
just keep running around like wild
monkeys out on the ice growing in
ferocity until it's this massive course
like Vishnu like this juggernaut
destroying everything in its path do you
want to be a chicken a goat a horse a
pig or a human in its way no you don't
you want to run really fast so here's a
200-foot deep meltwater Lake and you can
see it just drain out right there and
and this is I believe this is an image
per day so so this is across the the
length of a summer this is just one lake
and and once it blows out the ice seals
back up and the melt water gathers
behind it and and like I said that's
that's that's about 200 feet deep and
then boom it goes out so it goes out
rapidly and then it blasts out
downstream and and you go down into the
the valleys below and you just see well
this is this is where this isn't the
flood but this is this is where it enter
it would enter the the river this is the
real real Baker you go down into these
valleys and it and it just it's just
devastation what this this flood and hit
this valley and I think 1986 and it was
it was a forested valley with a fairly
narrow glacial plain in the middle with
a river come running across it and this
flood just took out everything in the
valley floor and I talked to the Gauchos
who saw it who got their livestock or
some of their livestock out and and they
just they were just just overwhelmed by
the sight of this water moving down the
boulders that are that are moving around
in this you know just huge rocks carried
down in these floods you're up in this
and you realize things move on this
planet things are not still everything
is turning and and you try to be there
when it's happening you get up there and
you look at a valley that has been
scoured out this is that down below the
Colonia glacier where the forests used
to run almost from wall to wall with a
with a river down the middle and it's
just cleared out I look for that I look
for those elemental places I look for
where the earth tells a story where it
makes you realize that you are on a
planet I think it's it's so easy to go
through our lives and not realize what
we're on top of it I forget all the time
until I walk out and look up and you
realize that you're on a ball in space
surrounded by others and you look at the
others you look at Mars and you go god
what happened there what went wrong and
you look the other way this is this is
an image of Venus without the clouds and
it's just like yeah another corpse over
there
and we're right in the middle just going
yeah what's what's happening around us
we live out in this we are floating out
there spinning we live around a star and
I think about what you know how thin the
layers are you you go to a place like
the Atacama Desert in northern Chile and
you see how thin the layers are you are
out there in a desert that is the driest
nonpolar desert in the world and the Sun
just feels naked on top of you I
traveled out there with with a friend of
mine a couple years ago and and this is
for the the book that I wrote
apocalyptic planet we were we were
trekking across the Atacama where we're
in the morning you you would start
walking toward your destination but the
the Sun would come up and start pushing
you the other way because you couldn't
walk into the light of the Sun your ear
here we're at about 8,000 feet in
elevation and it's just it's just dry
and clear and the Sun is burning through
you and you have to walk away from it
and and so the it's it's like trying to
sail through through a wind your your
your habit but the Sun is the wind you
keep it at your back and as it rises and
moves your course changes so all day
long you're keeping the Sun behind you
there's nothing out there to shade you
it is just this open dry desert places
where rain has not fallen for centuries
a desert that has existed there for a
hundred and fifty million years to me
one of the most beautiful places I have
seen where you find you find a bush and
this is this is alive because there are
19 thousand foot volcanoes on the
horizon where snow collects sometimes
and that snow melts runs down stream
goes underneath these solarz the these
big salt pans that are in the basins
between the mountains and and so saline
plants can grow down there we spent like
two hours at this bush
because it was the only thing and you
just you just crawl into it and it's
it's like it's something else that is
alive like you and and it's it's almost
like you're the same species because you
go hi good you're you're out here we're
out here - it's good to see you
because otherwise you're walking across
salt nothing but salt where the ridges
there are 2,000 foot high ridges out
there that are made entirely of salt
mixed with with sediment but you can eat
the ground you get down on your hands
and knees and taste it and you can taste
the the good clean salt and you can
taste the salt that that is full of
heavy metals and arsenic but you eat it
anyway because you have to how many
places can you get down and actually
taste the ground and the salt is it's
it's hard it is not a it is not a soft
substrate so it's like walking on glass
or at times if it sounds like you're
watching walking on crunchy armadillo
skins for four hours or four days and
and you're setting your camp out in
these out in these salt ridges I was
looking at this place and imagining okay
so this is the end of the world this is
this is you know the this Sun is is
going to be a planetary nebula soon the
the atmosphere is being stripped off
this is this is it this is this is what
it would look like the oceans boiled
away the mountains on the horizon might
be the Hawaiian island chain sticking up
and you're down at the bottom walking
around these these pillars of salt and
when the Sun rises the salt expands and
so it makes noise it pops so it's
actually it's kind of loud at times
where we're all around you you're
hearing these these crackles and pops
and Zing's of the the the salt expanding
and you you walk up to one of these
pillars and put your ear against it and
you can hear inside of it just these
it's it's it's a bizarre place you
should walk across this sometime it is
you you have to carry all your water so
you're walking with probably an 80 90
pound pack to start with and and every
night it gets cold enough that your
water freezes so that in the morning
you're walking along and the ice is
sloshing on your back and you're
spending your day walking away from the
Sun and then the Sun sets and the ice
are the the salt turns molten and then
the stars come out and just brilliant
sky down there so absolutely clear I
mean this this exposure couldn't have
been more than then 15 seconds so this
is what you were looking at you you're
just with your back against the salt
looking up at the sky as your water
freezes in your pack and in the morning
the Sun comes up and explodes across the
landscape where you walk for days and
you don't see a living thing you don't
see a blade of grass you don't see a fly
you don't see an ant it looks like the
surface of Mars this is a picture of
Mars here and that's where we were so
that's it you're on another planet right
now you're on a dead planet but then you
you find something out there you find
this this dead bush which is you know
pretty much life you know maybe there
are a bunch of these on Mars I'm II
should look around and see if there are
any of these bushes hanging out because
this is another one where I spent a lot
of time just on my knees in front of
this thing going it was here there was
life other things like us out in the
Atacama Desert things that somehow lived
here there's no shade
well there there is shade but it's down
in these holes these sinkholes you look
down into them this is the picture JT
took right then looking down into the
sinkhole and it's it's uh it's it's
basically razor blades of salt and so
but you want shade
so you got to you got to kind of wedge
yourself in and climb down and get into
the bottom of one of these things and
it's it's nice and cool down there but
it's hard and I don't like the idea of
falling you know falling ripping
yourself apart on salt just just sounds
awful but you're this is where you take
your shelter down in the bottom of these
holes looking up at the the circle of
the sky like you're down inside of some
kind of well drilled down into the salt
I love this stuff I live for this to go
out and wander across it walking across
these solarz I had kind of hoped that
this was gonna be like the the salar de
uni in bolivia which is this this
enormous salt flat that is actually flat
you could wall you can roll a cue ball
across it and I and I said oh great
we're gonna go to one of those solarz
and it's gonna be flat and we're gonna
walk across it and it's gonna be bizarre
and it turned out to be like walking
across a coral reef with it took it took
hours to make make half a mile and and
when you're looking for a place to sleep
out here you're walking in the dark with
your headlamp for hours and hours
looking for any place soft because you
cannot sit down in this stuff it just
tears the the ass out of your pants it's
this it's an awful place but you get out
into the middle of it where this that
where the the snowmelt has gone down
underneath the salar and and the the
salt formations are growing up out of it
and it is like coming across life but
it's its life in the form of just salt
these these beautiful shapes almost like
marine organisms and then and we found
water there we found these these holes
and and you taste it in it you'd have to
spit it out right away because it's it's
saltier than seawater but but to find
water in this is this dry dry place it
doesn't matter if you
and trinket you just hang out there
again for this is what I do you know I
wander around in complete desolation
looking for some little thing that I can
sit there and go oh my God look at it
it's real it's something to focus your
attention on I mean you find a dead cow
out there and it is a party it is a war
just incredible and you look down into
these water holes and and the salt
crystals are growing inside of them we
actually we found one there was there
was flowing out it was coming out of a
hole and and flowing across the Salar so
so there was this river with with with
with salt grasses growing in places
along the margins and and I remember the
first morning we came across this this
river the we the ice was in our packs
and the the Sun was was was coming on so
it was rapidly getting hotter and every
morning these mirages would start
spreading these these beautiful silver
mirages that are reflecting the
mountains in the distance so it looks
like you're in the middle of this silver
lake and then it gets really strange
because pink flamingos come flying in
over your head and the flamingos are
coming and straining brine shrimp out of
out of these water sources but that's
where you're where you're just you're at
the end of the world and and there are
flamingos and and you're just looking at
it saying yes this is what the planet is
about I mean take it all the way out and
there will still be something somehow I
while writing this book I I spent time
interviewing the the biologist CEO
Wilson and and would go to his study in
Harvard and we would just we would sit
and talk about extinction and and he was
saying I asked him how far can how far
is too far how far can you take it
before it's just over on this planet and
he just smiled he said I think you know
the answer to that question you know you
can take it all the way you can you can
kill off everything and still there
would be microbes here so life wouldn't
end but do you really want to take it
that far do you really want to see the
world end like that
and out in the Atacama there have been a
core is taken out of the out of the salt
and microbes have been found suspended
in inhe light inside of the cores that
have been revived after 40,000 years and
and so I you know you you realize that
the life is is very resilient on this
planet it lives inside of the the salt
but that's not life that's not the
Holocene that's not this moment I'm
interested in seeing what the end looks
like but I want to come back I want to
come back to the world I want to leave
this place and come back to where the
trees are growing to where you can drink
clean water I'm interested in these
places where thing has changed I'm
interested in where where where the
crust of the planet breaks a I've been
thinking about asteroids crust being
broken from above or volcanoes the crust
being broken from below I I've always
wanted to get out around live lava so I
traveled out on actually with JT the
same person I was with in the Atacama we
we walked out into into the on the Big
Island of Hawaii into the east wrist own
where where there had been subdivisions
and and and pieces of jungle several
weeks before and the flow had completely
covered them over and and we spent time
with with a guy living in the last house
at the edge of the lava flow and he was
so excited about this and his house has
since burned down and he would he just
couldn't wait for it to happen he was
this this lava junkie who you know you'd
be sitting in a drinking tea with him
and looking out the kitchen window and
you're just looking at total devastation
out there just this is black steaming
masses of rock and and you're drinking
tea going oh my god we we are at the
edge and and he he told me what to watch
out for the places to walk the places
not to walk and and he showed me over
over
period of weeks as I came and visited
with him how the lava around him was was
rising and falling that the the hardened
lava was you can see where where it was
where the the actual liquid lava
underneath was pushing up and he's just
going any day one of those is gonna blow
it's gonna break and it's gonna start
coming out and so we waited until you
could see a little bit of glow at night
and then my friend and I put on our
packs and headed out into this walking
through this this just beautiful
landscape of devastation of what had
been houses and and big ohia trees and
now was this blackness that that uh you
know you could you could call it the end
but it looks like the beginning it looks
like the first forms on the earth it
looks like the first orchid the first
fiddle neck the the first violin being
formed right here the shapes that are
eventually the earth are being made
right in front of you we'd set our camp
out in these places where we're you know
in some spots you you can't sit down
it's like walking across a a the top of
a wood stove and you're just kind of
you're moving fast and and you spit on
the ground and it it it doesn't sizzle
but it dries up quickly and you know we
would be capping our sticks going hmm
how this sounds kind of hollow like when
it when it breaks through what it's
what's it like to fall into a pit of
lava what does it feel like to be
tumbling down into it we'd come across
these these these these formations tomb
you lie these these are these blisters
and the the air above them is just is
just blurred with the heat that's coming
out and you you walk up and you you feel
this column of heat you don't get too
close but close enough that you can feel
this this heat just shooting straight
out of the ground and you look for it at
night you look for the glow and you head
for it and it is this this amazing front
of lava moving about that
fast at least where we were and and just
picking up pieces of rock and and and
you know picking up what had been liquid
the night before and carrying it along
you hear these these scratches and these
pops and hisses as gluttonous masses of
lava come pouring out turning black and
then opening again and rivers picking up
speed and closing down and damming and
pouring all around you and you're you're
having to keep track to make sure you're
not closed off by any of it you can't
get too close you can get five feet away
and it strips the sweat off of your face
you can get three feet away and it feels
like your eyeballs are gonna pop that's
about as close as you want to get but
you've got to see it because it's coming
out of the ground and flowing around you
this is what is under our feet
all the time this is what is pushing
tectonics pushing continental continents
into each other tectonic plates moving
around each other I I read around the
video camera and just just took images
of or took little clips of the lava as
its forming these these beautiful
bellies like like the Sun coming out
from inside of the the planet I was I
carried a penny in my pocket as maybe an
offering that that I was gonna go up and
throw it into the lava and watch it and
melt I I had this vision like like when
in Lord of the Rings when Gollum fell
into the lava and the ring melted that's
what was gonna happen I was gonna throw
it in and I imagine the lava was gonna
be like pudding and it was just gonna
sink into it and melt and and I had this
whole idea in my head of just saying
okay this represents my civilization
this is this is human history right here
and I'm gonna throw it in and just watch
this the the enormity of the planet
swallow it so I lifted it back I threw
it in and it went ping and it bounced
right off and at that moment I realized
where we are this isn't putting coming
out of the earth this is molten steel we
are on this molten ball where it's
pushing up underneath
our feet all the time pressing against
the surface of the planet it's easy to
imagine the surface of the planet is
what is here is is that it's it's the
it's the oceans it's it's the crust it's
that it's where we farm where we live
but it is so thin and you go to these
places where you can feel it underneath
you the reason I was traveling there I
wanted to see succession I wanted to see
what happens when when when a
subdivision and a forest get they get
just taken back to zero and and how long
it takes for life to come back into
these places and they're there these
these features that are known as Kapoor
cos Kapooka is a place where the lava
flows around something and so you have
lava to the horizon all around you and
then you have this little forest in the
middle where it just happened to go
around this one spot here's a Kapooka
from from a couple decades ago where
this was a subdivision and it's
completely surrounded by lava and no
there is one house out there I believe
where somebody still lives
these Kapoor cos reseed the lava this is
where life comes from that goes back
into the lava there the crickets and the
spiders come out of these forests the
seeds blow out into the lava the the the
ferns send their rhizomes down and start
breaking apart the the glassy rock and
turning in into soil this is lava that's
about I believe this is this is four
years old
so these Kapoor cos seed the future and
and in an apocalyptic planet I'm using
Kapoor cos as as the model as as this is
this is what you want to have on this
planet you need a lot of Kapoor cos you
need all kinds of ecosystems that have
just strong ecological capacity you you
want you want to hold on to two pieces
of Great Lakes ecosystems
coastal ecosystems sand dunes prairie
grass alpine areas as many Kapooka as
you can get as many refuges because when
the lava comes that's what makes a
healthy planet that what that's what
makes this planet resilient you have a
lot of ecosystems that are ready to go
if you if you look back into the Earth's
history where you know there have been
plenty times that that there have been
large bolide impacts asteroids have hit
the planet and you do not see much of a
reaction in the fossil record as
compared to the the dinosaur extinction
65 million years ago where you where you
see an impact and you see a reaction in
the the record I think what's going on
is asteroids are hitting at times when
the earth is really healthy and it
doesn't devastate the planet whereas if
you look at the dinosaur extinction
prior to the the the Chicxulub impact
health was going down fossils are
disappearing the planet is not so
healthy so it's primed for a mass
extinction when the asteroid hits at a
point where the planet is not healthy
where there aren't many kapu cos the
thing crashes and so I'm looking at the
planet now going ok this is one of those
moments where you don't want an asteroid
to hit this is one of those moments
where the planet doesn't seem to be
particularly healthy where species
extinction is is ramping up where we're
losing its this is not when you want to
have it happen but it's not just
asteroids hitting it's us we are one of
the asteroids hitting the planet we are
something that is coming on fast and
changing landscapes on a huge scale
around the planet changing chemical
balances in the atmosphere in the ocean
so we are one of those things that is
that is altering this planet this is the
moment you don't want something else to
happen and we're living as if as if
nothing else will happen as if we are
the only variable here so I went out
looking to see what happens after the
devastation I went out to see the Ohia
plants and the ferns growing back into
the lava to see the the pioneer species
coming out you know the people coming
out the people you know they're humans
are another one of this species setting
up shop building on top of the law
putting out the lawn chairs we are
growing out there on this solid rock
this is this is a forest that is that is
about 50 years old that has grown onto
the lava then you go into a tree fern
forest on lava that is 400 years old and
life has moved back in life has
swallowed this place the this is a
native tree fern forest just a bizarre
place because there are no trails in
there there to travel through you're
just climbing through windows in the
vegetation the the landscape looks as if
you could turn it upside down and it
would you couldn't tell the difference
it is just life coming out of the ground
and the canopy looks like the ground
above you
you're just within this plant kingdom
originally in in in in Hawaii at least a
pre human contact with Hawaii
there are only two native mammals a bat
and a seal and so there weren't any land
animals the largest herbivore in Hawaii
was a duck so you didn't have animals
moving through these forests so this
forest looks like what Hawaii looked
like before people were there I've been
in jungles in different parts of the
world and they're always animal trails
and this was the bazaars place because
there were no there were no trails there
this was a plant Kingdom and I'm looking
at this thinking okay so this is after
some devastation something terrible has
happened on earth and this is what comes
back what's missing here mammals we're
gone in fact there are very few insects
in this forest
the only time you really find mosquitoes
out there are when feral pigs root up
these these these tree ferns and cause
them to fall over leaving these holes
where water collects and you get
mosquitoes so most of what's going on
out here are our plants and you know
there are birds but the the native
native species of birds of they're
almost entirely gone from Hawaii but
this was my hope this is where I was
looking at it saying you know it's not
about us coming back it's about the
world living on
that you can't destroy this planet but
do you want to wait ten million years
for life to come back which that's about
how long it takes for biodiversity to
return after a after a mass extinction
event so I you know sometimes I take the
geologic view and I step back and I say
you know what it's gonna be fine the
world is a beautiful place it's
resilient yes it may be destroyed by us
or some other event but it will come
back the earth has seen worse than it is
seeing right now but then we haven't
seen worse the species around us haven't
seen worse and when I think about this
you know I think about the end I think
about different ways that the things
could come apart and and after writing
apocalyptic planet the worst ending that
I could imagine
I finally found here in Iowa this is a
GMO corn field in central Iowa where I
hooked up with a friend of mine I don't
know why he came with me on this trip
this was the most miserable thing I've
ever done in my life we we went to
Central Iowa in July the height of
summer we put on packs and we backpacked
across GMO fields for three days and and
what I was looking for was was a
landscape that that resembled a mass
extinction and I looked around the world
at different environments at the the the
aral sea at Chad Lake Chad you know
places that are just devastated and
finally I realized oh it's Iowa that's
what a mass extinction looks like we're
where everything that used to be there
is gone and replaced by just a handful
of species and you put on your pack and
you head into the corn and as soon as
you walk through those first layers you
disappear the place just swallows you
you've got to cover yourself when you're
walking in there the the the leaves are
fairly stiff and they they especially
hit you right on the bridge irnos
because you're just you're pushing
through a wall of leaves and then you
bleeding down your nose which I don't
think in a place that's just primarily
anhydrous ammonia and pesticide and
herbicides that you really want to be
having many open wounds so you you cover
your face of the bandana and you tuck it
up underneath your sunglasses so that
that you won't start bleeding if the
bridge of your nose and this is what it
looks like all the time you're just
pushing through torn leaves and you
can't see out of it the the the canopy
of the corn is about eight feet tall so
you you get the sprinkling of the sky
and when we were out there it was a
meteorological anomaly called a heat
dome where 900 new high records were set
across the continent and the nearest
record high to us on the on the dew
point was a hundred and twenty-nine
degrees Fahrenheit so basically you're
you're in this place where it feels like
you just climbed out of a hot tub fully
dressed
you were just drenched and dripping on
yourself and like I said this is this is
it this is the this is your experience
hours and hours of moving through this
hemmed in on either side by like
cornrows just wide enough that your pack
can fit through but you can't quite turn
around and look behind you oh yeah as I
went into this I originally I thought
you know maybe this is a new sport that
I'm inventing that corn backpacking is
gonna be great like it'll be great for
the blind too because you can't over
here you're going straight oh I'm
running out of power that happens
that's how it ends you know work give me
a second here you just have to plug it
in over and over again until it finally
comes on there we go I think there
enough of that god that was horrible I
it just it was it was a really awful
experience in many ways angus i he were
friends again but my my my purpose out
there was to see if anything else was
alive in the cornfields and and I come
back to tell you that not much is alive
in the cornfields you know there there
are some tiny little mushrooms growing
in there and and and there are things
there are a deer that that come through
we we did run into one late one night
but it's it's hard to even find an
insect out there everything is
miniaturized there they're the smallest
of spiders the smallest of ants and not
very many of them you can crawl on your
hands and knees for for 20 minutes
before you finally find some other
living thing in there but you know
sometimes you will see a grasshopper but
the grasshoppers most insects stay to
the outside of the the cornfield the
edges because the the there's a gene
that's in the corn that is a pesticide
so the the corn is actually a poison to
the insects so so there's this this race
between the grasshoppers and the genetic
engineers to because the grasshoppers
are adapting there they're getting
deeper into the corn and the genetic
engineers are pushing them back and I'm
I'm thinking that this is this is a
high-speed evolution going on right here
and the future of the planet is going to
be corn and grasshoppers and everything
that radiates out from them and this is
this isn't a tall grass prairie but this
is what's out there this is this is this
actually used to be a cornfield this is
two years after a cornfield and it has
been replanted and burned and planted
and burned and
and they're trying to get native grasses
to grow back in here and so it was
heartening for me to go check out a
place like this where where you can say
okay two years ago this was this was
just this was monoculture this this was
you know death this was mass extinction
and and life is coming back to this
place but think that right now the Iowa
ninety percent of the land the surface
area of Iowa is under agricultural
production ninety percent of a landscape
turned to corn and soybeans and and the
the the farmers out there that the the
farmer that I spent time with who owns
this field they're just there there's
such hospitable wonderful people and and
I talked to him about this dilemma I
said you know what this is is this right
is this supposed to be this way and he
said you know we're we had seven billion
people on the planet and my job is to
keep food moving that this is what I do
I'm part of this thing this is my job
and and and I understood what he was
saying that you can't have an
agricultural collapse when you're
relying on this kind of production that
this that he is keeping people alive and
and and where does that go seven billion
to ten billion to fifteen billion to
thirty billion you know where does where
does that end the reason I say that this
is the most terrifying future I can
imagine is because this is humans
covering everything this is what I don't
want to see I don't want to see us
everywhere Angus didn't want to see us
everywhere either he was I think you
know just a few hours into this he was
he was sick of the whole trip and you
die you you drop into the bottom of the
corn rose and just just lie there
breathing just gasping and and then
you're if you're not moving up high
you're dropped into the row and this is
your view you you finally have a little
bit of a view right you know if you're
down like an ankle high you can kind of
see around and above you is just this
this ceiling of of corn leaves and Angus
is just hating it I'm [ __ ] tired of
thinking hot and sticky and dirty
can you say [ __ ] in this book and you
have to write you have to eat the corn
and and I was I was talking to some some
researchers working in and on on looking
at gene transfer horizontal gene
transfer where where genes can actually
pass through a genetically modified
organism into another species and and
they were saying oh this is extremely
rare you know you don't have to worry
about it you know as long as you weren't
like eating corn right there at the
source and as long as you weren't just
covered in in it and I'm just going oh
my god because we felt like grimy and
fib Ian's out there we were just it was
it was it was stuck to us because the
soil is is like the shoe polish it's
it's not even soil anymore and and this
is what I'm afraid of I'm afraid that we
just keep going that we don't stop that
we we plant everything and there's
nothing left we consume the entire
planet because I many of the scientists
that I spoke to said just just out of
hand they said oh yeah humans we're not
gonna last you know we're we're short
for this world we're we're we're gone
we're practically gone at this point and
I would say well where's your evidence
for that and they'd say well it's
obvious and and and I realize this is
just a gut feeling that humans aren't
gonna last and I look at the species and
think wow this is one of the more
adaptable species on this planet you
know maybe not as individuals but as a
species yes our civilizations come and
go languages societies they they they
rise and fall but this species I think
is going to outlive many others I think
we will kill off everything in order to
survive that's why I'm afraid of this
future why I'm afraid of the corn
because I don't want to kill everything
so that we can live I want there to be
Kapoor cos I want there to be seeds
ready to go all over the planet
ecosystems that are ready ecosystems
that are thriving I don't want to
consume everything I want there to be
something out there that doesn't smell
like uh
we set our we set our camp on these uh
on these places kind of balded by excess
herbicides where you could you could
actually find some ground this is a this
is a drainage they don't irrigate here
there's already water in the soil
they're actually trying to get water out
of the soil so there was this drainage
right through the middle that let the
water out and that's where the
grasshoppers could live and it you walk
into it and there are thousands of
grasshoppers rising in front of you and
and I was I was wearing a silk shirt
which I wear when I travel in the desert
and I thought I was being mr. summer
traveler I'm wise I'm wearing a silk
shirt it was an awful thing to be
wearing it was it was like wearing a wet
tongue because it was just always wet
and stuck to you and then then one day I
found that the grasshoppers were eating
my silk shirt and so they're eating
holes in my shirt but it's so damn hot
that you don't care you're just
stumbling ahead and looking down and
they're grasshoppers on you and they're
eating and you're just going I don't
care I just want this to end and at
night you just beg for a breeze for
anything to move because it is so still
and you're just sitting naked in your
tent just trying not to touch the walls
of the tent because if you did the whole
tent would just stick to your face and
the last morning things changed the last
morning a rain storm came in and I
thought oh this will be marvelous it's
gonna rain and it was awful too because
it was just hot water falling out of the
sky and you're just standing there and
the corn just soaked with hot water and
I was waiting for Angus to come by
because I knew that I'd catch catch
something witty on camera he would stop
we would have some conversation I would
get a little clip so I just stood there
waiting for him
[Applause]
Angus who just utterly hates me at this
point
[Applause]
who wants nothing but to get out but
you'll you'll notice here there are some
trees on the horizon and and we found
something that we had not expected on on
one of the sides of the the cornfield
was this forty acre Wildlife Refuge that
I had I it was it was a miracle to see
it to go into this place where where
things are actually alive it's not it's
something that's not corn I mean there
are soybeans out there I didn't mention
that and and so it's not just a
monoculture there are two species but
here you get into this this forest and
and there are mushrooms there there are
birds there I mean in the in the corn
we'd wait hours and hours and you'd see
some shadow go by and you go oh bird and
that would be a big moment and here the
the trees were full of birds and and I
did you know I mentioned this place - yo
Wilson and he said was it a real forest
or was it just all non natives that were
brought in there and and yes he's right
it is not a true it's it definitely its
own ecosystem but everything was was
brought in everything in fact when you
start looking around you realize this
was a completely manufactured Wildlife
Refuge where a dead tree snag looked
like it was about to fall there are a
bunch of trees around it that had been
girdled by a chainsaw so that when that
tree falls there'll be a bunch of other
dead snags they're ready to replace that
tree that single tree habitat so this
this is totally managed but it's it's
still wild and and when we as we looked
around we we found that oh this is an
old Arboretum this is an old tree museum
there there were these these signs and
and benches you know people don't come
back in here anymore but it was it was a
place where where people would come and
sit and look at trees and you see this
this black cherry sign just being
overwhelmed by lichens and for me this
was hope this is just me saying yes yes
life comes back it springs back out you
can't stop it Angus Angus was still not
impressed
and what I expected this trip had
nothing witty for you stopped returning
me a jet subsidy here take another life
this isn't gonna be your like a useless
at all it's not gonna be useful
expecting to be a witty moment in your
show
[Applause]
so walking through this forest we found
a creek they call them pricks there and
the farmer had told me don't go swimming
in the creek they're not safe places and
when I went down and looked at the creek
I lifted up rocks and I realized why
they're not safe there's nothing living
in there there you know you usually pull
up a rock and it's covered with with
little invertebrates crawling all over
it and there was just nothing at all but
still it was water flowing through oak
trees it was water flowing through brush
and we we found a bridge and we walked
across it and just stood there for a
while listening to the rain falling out
of the trees and landing in the water
and yeah I'm afraid for the future I'm
afraid for what will happen I I worry
about us just continuing on and on that
we will cover this planet that we will
change everything that we will geo
engineer and and turn everything into
agriculture and pave it over until this
is a concrete ball and I know that there
are other futures I know that the ice
will return I know that glaciers will
flow again that you'll go up to Yosemite
someday maybe ten thousand years from
now maybe fifty thousand maybe ten
million years and there will be ice
pouring out of those mountains nothing
stays the same on this planet everything
changes there is no singular trajectory
we are not heading toward a devastated
ball floating in space this planet is
alive this planet is changing all the
time and I travel out there looking for
these places I look for where things end
because I want to see how they begin I
don't want to just see devastation out
there I want to see life crawling across
this globe I want to see ice coming and
going I want to see these seasons moving
in and out of each other and I want to
be out in the middle of it as it's
happening which is why I'm here which is
why I was in Yosemite why I put my back
against that rock and felt the glaciers
pouring around me because we live on
this planet you walk out that door and
it will be out there you will
mallet you will see it up in the sky we
live in this place go out there breathe
it in thank you for coming and listening
tonight
thank you
you know what got me on that last bit on
the bridge was the sound of a Midwestern
thunder yeah which we don't have here I
grew up in northern Illinois and those
cornfields and those thunderstorms were
sort of the the planetary thing that
happened to us you'd see the wall rain
come up the street and just feel oh yeah
this is summer all right we got some
questions here
Hannah asked what is the most stable
unchanging place on earth now I might be
the Atacama Desert yeah well what did
you save millions of years really uh I
think a hundred and fifty million years
is how long but it does that place
fluctuates too because those solarz are
formed by wetter periods mmm where where
snow melt is coming down into the end of
the basins and then drying and leaving
the salt formations why is it so stable
oh the Andes pretty fixed really yeah
it's there's a dry current coming in off
of Antarctica so that's a that's a
current that has been there for a very
long time it's it's always pushing up
against the the edge of edge of well not
it hasn't always been South America but
then you also you have mountain ranges
that have been continuously building and
causing a rain shadow so those two
things are keeping that place really dry
I'm sure there are other there biotic
least a stable places looks like sham
what is the place you would like to
experience but can't go to space reduced
it I want to go backpacking on Mars
backpacking Amarth
but I you can't go barefoot which which
is gonna keep me from going there but I
didn't see you going barefoot in the
Atacama every once in while I Mars is I
because of the scale of that place
because it it doesn't have the plate
tectonics the earth has so when there's
a volcano it just keeps coming up in the
same spot and definitely enormous
landscape
so so even though it's a smaller planet
it has bigger features a little less
gravity so you can yeah and then you
make a longer day but you can't go
barefoot so much heavier pack hay right
you got your water it's lighter you must
have a list of places you're still dying
to go to what's on it Oh everywhere you
know actually where this this probably
isn't the answer that person wants but I
or that you want I I want to go back
home I want to I want to go to the
southwest of the canyons of the Colorado
Plateau and the Sonoran Desert the
places where I I I'm kind of a home
person I really I like to go back to the
same Canyon season after season so I
really know all the boulders so you know
traveling the world has been a
fascinating experience but I'm really
I'm focused on on being in looks like
you do in these exotic places is if
there are people there you try to
connect with the ones who lives there
who do for whom it is home right and so
you get a contrast between you as a
newbie experiencing the instant
weirdness of it all and these people who
are really engaging it the way you are
on the southwest how does how this was
play against each other well I'm a
stranger in those places so it's it's
I'm I'm out of my element for one of the
chapters in that book I was on an island
in the Bering Sea
there was a yupik eskimo island so there
were two villages I was at one of the
villages and and they had such an
understanding of their place they'd been
there for 2,000 years and and and I had
no idea where I was or how to get around
and I said you know I just want to walk
out there and they're saying well polar
bears wolves no you can't just walk out
there and hunting territories are all
over the place and you're just gonna
walk right across them and not even know
that they're there so it's it's hard for
me to drop into a place where I don't
know what
what the dynamics are and but then I
slowly learn from you know the you picks
after after nine days they finally say
okay now you can walk now you can leave
the village and head out and explore so
you're home
46 how long have you been in the part of
the Southwest we are now oh all my life
like Arizona Colorado back and forth
between the two what's the rate of since
you keep going out there and keep going
some of the same places or you keep
discovering new things there's the
comfort that you don't discover new
things that it's all familiar no I
discover new things I I I've gone down
the green river through Canyon lands
down to the confluence of the Colorado
which is a hundred mile stretch of river
probably 35 times now and every time at
the beginning of the trip I'm just going
yeah you know this stuff is gonna happen
you're gonna find canyons you've never
seen you're gonna you know you're gonna
come across rock art there there's
always something now that seems like
kind of a when I visited it seems like a
really stable landscape but you go to
the same River 35 times is it different
each time oh yeah the flash floods are
blowing debris out into the river and so
the river is changing every every season
and and canyon floors are changing where
you get in there and it had been
boulders last year and now it's just
sand mm-hm
and right now this is the season the big
flash floods are running out there so
things are changing but you wouldn't see
it unless you saw it year by year
it looks stable in your broker house
reyne you were served exploring what
drove the ancient peoples of the
southwest
hither and yon with climate and conflict
and so on if it was just them living
there now in the current sort of climate
situation in southwest what would they
be doing would they be on the move from
north or to higher they'd be heading
south probably south into Mexico
yeah South out of the Colorado Plateau
into central Arizona and Mexico and
probably into the Rio Grande area this
would this would be one of the times
where they'd they'd start consolidating
head toward water basic right right it's
is that happening amongst the current
civilization
well we're bringing water to us no we do
it differently until you run out of
water and that right a place where you
go Mexico there's a cave that has has
enormous crystals in it it's a hot cave
I'd only stay in it for a short period
of time I want to go in and see those
crystals is that doable it's doable
people have gone in yeah yeah I don't
I've I've had some contacts but then
lost you know there's there's only so
much one can do well hang in you're
working on the book now tell us about
the book I'm writing about the first
people to enter North America during the
Ice Age so it's a book that starts
28,000 years ago and ends 5,000 years
ago so I'm I've been traveling up in the
Bering Land Bridge area and and my
reason for skiing across the Harding
Icefield was to to get an idea of what
it would be like to have to cross ice
granted from a 21st century perspective
but that's kind of what this book is
about is saying well here we are with
21st century gear trying to understand a
Pleistocene world but I'm trying to
bring North America back up and say this
is what it was like during the
Pleistocene this is this is where the
mammoths were this is the range of dire
wolves of the horses and camels here's
what people were eating here's how they
were hunting here's where the
populations were starting to grow here
these the first kind of shadows and
rumors of people you know where people
may have been 40 50 thousand years ago
but it's not certain but here's where
they were 23 thousand years ago here's
where they were twenty-eight thousand
years ago so are you're there's a number
of theories that when people came and
where they came and what you did in the
southwest is by walking the land get
your own sense of what which theories
were right and wrong about what happened
there are you getting a sense of which
theories are right and around them for
money about when when and how people got
yeah and I think in in house of rain I
have learned that in a way all the
theories are right they're all fighting
against each other but when you put them
all together you know all this was
happening
and that's what I'm seeing so far where
where it's not just that people came
across the land bridge or people came
from the Iberian Peninsula and then died
out on the East Coast or the people came
down the the the Pacific Rim people were
coming from everywhere that there were
multiple points of entry depending on
you know the the ice was was leaving the
the inside passage of British Columbia
17,000 years ago and so there was a
there was a coastal passage that was
open and then the inside the the
ice-free corridor opened up in in
Alberta 13,000 years ago so you you can
see these different times that people
are moving in and so you're recreating
all revisiting all of the routes yeah
I'm trying to travel all the different
ways that people would have come in and
crossed the continent so one theory
relatively recent is that they came
along the west coast by water I guess
they want the beach and by boat and so
on and therefore were able to go quite a
long way fairly early on is that your
sense of things yeah because you're
finding these these these middens bone
mittens where where people are eating
fish that are deep-sea fish ha so
they're going out to get them and you
know they're out canoes or kayaks or
what we guess there's nothing I'm I was
looking at it ooh me ax the the big the
walrus skin boats that they're using up
and or the day no they still use them in
the Bering Sea of Western Alaska and and
they're they're fairly easy to build in
there they're sturdy but it's not like
people are just racing this is taking
thousands of years of just moving down
living moving out farther living moving
out farther so its generation by
generation well I wonder about that cuz
um one of the things that got from house
reyne is that people move farther faster
than many of the anthropologists and
archaeologists thought yeah and that
since they hadn't walked the land they
hadn't got the
you can just walk away and keep going
and go for a few weeks and you're a long
way from where you started yeah and then
there's people like you who just want to
light out for their horizon and it seems
like every society has I mean how could
Polynesians have gone from Island Isle
across the Pacific heading to absolutely
a horizon with nothing on it except you
know fond hope and yet they would go
those long distances so wouldn't it be a
combination of you know sort of this
village gets too big in the screw a
Trottier and they make another village
with all the way south but they're
following the trail of the characters
like you just said screw it I'm really
Ally I want to see what's out I
definitely think there were there were
people who were just who just could not
stay still I mean we're always there
every species has individuals who are
just have to go and most of them
probably disappear but some get
somewhere and set up shop I mean when
when I came across the ice field my
object there was to say hey here's a
bunch of Crusaders we're just out to
have an adventure and then the next trip
was my family coming up and meeting
meeting me and in Alaska and we went out
with kayaks on onto Prince William Sound
and and I could say okay this is
probably more what it looked like like
yeah there were the people going across
like yes we're we're exploring we're
seeing what's next but then comes the
family and and you're not just out
exploring you're here figuring out how
many snacks do you have available to you
and that's it's a combination of the two
I'm sure that that drives human
migration well we got to every continent
including lately Antarctica yeah where
now we're gonna try other continents in
the solar system called planets we are
excited to move which scares me I know
I'm the leading edge of that and you
know my kind of person is the one who's
going yes yes there's got to be more you
know I am the reason that this has
happened you know that we've the people
like me if just gone let's keep going
let's build more cities and and keep
exploring and so I often look at my my
drive and say yeah this is what's wrong
with us we we can't stop and I but I
love there there is this desire to move
to see well you know what is around the
corner what what keeps going I would say
lighten up on yourself and I think that
your love of these reduced places of the
wilderness is part of what lets
everybody
appreciate and honor them and be
determined to help protect them so
you're going there and looking brings
with it the sense of care and protection
thank you for doing it thank you for
having me
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]